far away from the politics of
Westminster circus starmer today in
Scotland with a serious policy plan to
transform the UK into a green Powerhouse
the reality is this
the moment for decisive action is now
the man who wants to be PM with a pledge
that all electricity be generated from
low carbon sources be that nuclear wind
solar by 2030 done through a
state-funded company to invest in clean
power headquartered in Scotland and with
subsidies for thousands of green jobs
paid for by a hundred billion pounds or
more of borrowing we've got to seize the
new opportunities we can cut bills
create jobs and provide energy security
for Britain that's what a labor
government will deliver
but the plan expensive labor in recent
days scaling back its commitments you
have already u-turned on your 28 billion
pound a year investment into green
transition Your Shadow Chancellor said
it shows you can be trusted with the
public finances but doesn't it also
suggest as with brexit tuition fees
nationalizations you're just like all of
those other politicians uh on the 28
billion we are doubling down we're not
backing off so there's nothing here to
read into any sense of lacking ambition
or backing down not backing down instead
pressing on kiss Starman came to be seen
here doesn't it speak volumes that the
labor party is today launching a plan
for the next generation of jobs whilst
the tourists are squabbling back in
Westminster the SMP are preaching about
promises that they have broken publicly
arm and driving forward his missions for
a labor government but this leader knows
too to deliver is a gigantic task clean
Power by 2030 so all of our electricity
from renewals is that a guarantee or is
it a Target it's it's the ambition and
it's doable so it's not a guarantee
because you might fall short because it
is so ambitious what I've done is I've
sat down with the sector and said this
is what I want to achieve is it possible
for us to achieve it so it's not just a
Target that hasn't been thought through
from the industry cautious optimism the
target for a decarbonized power sector
by 2030 at the moment you know the IE
which is the International Energy agency
says that all developed countries need
to achieve that by 2035 at the latest so
this is in line with the climate science
but political opponents less convinced
Lionel should we trust a labor party
that in successive UK governments has
squandered not tens but how hundreds of
billions of oil and gas revenue and not
invested but a fraction back into
Scotland with Westminster bogged down in
the Boris Johnson Psycho Drama still and
the SMP reeling from the implosion of
Nicholas stargen sarkir starmer here in
Scotland has just announced the single
most radical policy of his government
should he win the next general election
billions and billions of public money
funneled into the green economy but
voters taking a look at him might be
wondering why he's not putting that
money into public services like
hospitals and schools instead
for now Smiles the polls and prospects
for this party positive this part of the
country crucial to any Victory and these
politicians not taking anything for
granted Beth Rigby Sky News in Leith